[Musica]
anche se l'argomento di cui vi parlerò
oggi e l'intelligenza artificiale
voglio iniziare raccontando vedi
qualcosa molto umano
il pregiudizio pregiudizio è farsi
vedere qualcosa a priori senza avere
un'esperienza diversa per esempio i
capelli rossi è una volta c'è
pregiudizio che noi cambiamo i capelli
rossi fossimo cattivi fossimo dei
vampiri fossimo dei lupi mannari e a
causa di questi pregiudizi c'era perfino
chi voleva utilizzare il nostro sangue
per trasformare il rame in oro
esistono per giudizi di tutti i tipi
verso gli italiani verso gli stranieri
verso i ricchi verso i poveri e anche se
pregiudizio generalmente pensato come
qualcosa di negativo esistono anche pre
giudizi positivi come per esempio gli
svizzeri sono tutti puntuali o le donne
scandinave sono altre belle un altro
pregiudizio molto comune è che il
pregiudizio stesso sia tipico degli
umani e che le macchine che
l'intelligenza artificiale missioni
immuni ma è proprio vero
facciamo un esempio la forma di
pregiudizio più comune quella cui siamo
tutti abituati purtroppo il razzismo
contro le persone di colore che vengono
spesso insultate per il colore della
loro pelle
siamo tutti tristemente abituati agli
episodi negli stadi in cui queste
persone vengono paragonate alle scimmie
vengono fatti
bersani ma le ski vengono persino
lanciate banane
allora direte voi cosa c'entra tutto
questo con l'intelligenza artificiale
non è che un bel giorno un algoritmo si
metterà a dare delle scimmie alle
pressioni di colore non è che google
apple o facebook rischierebbero di
mettere in commercio o qualcosa del
genere
[Musica]
invece nel 2015 è successo questo
google aveva da poco introdotto una
funzione di categorizzazione automatica
in photos la sua applicazione per la
gestione delle immagini è l'algoritmo di
machine learning ha preso categorizzare
le persone di colore come bollirla non è
poca bella pubblicità vero e non è
neanche un caso isolato
face app un'applicazione che vi permette
di applicare dei filtri basati sul
machine learning sulle vostre immagini è
stata fortemente criticata perché il
filtro che va a far apparire le
pressioni più belle
se applicato sulle persone di colore le
faceva sembrare più bianche link ed
invece è stata accusata di sessismo
perché fino a qualche tempo fa se voi
cercavate nel social network il nome di
una donna per esempio francesca rossi il
motore di ricerca vi suggeriva francesco
rossi quasi a dire che gli uomini
manassero meglio per lavori delle donne
anche un algoritmo analizzata da
ricercatori dell'università della
virginia è stato posato di razzi di
sessismo perché quando mostravano questo
algoritmo una rete neurale delle scene
di persone in cucina si mostravano un
uomo ai fornelli
l'algoritmo diceva che c'era una donna
ora che cosa sta succedendo
l'intelligenza artificiale sta imparando
i nostri dati peggiori ci sono degli
algoritmi razzisti sessisti misogini
ignoranti o peggio tutte queste
tecnologie sono sviluppate le persone
pieni di pregiudizi
beh niente di tutto questo ma allora
perché succede tutto ciò per capirlo
cerchiamo di capire come funziona un
algoritmo di machine learning
immaginiamo di dover addestrare un
algoritmo a capire che taglia di
maglietta portano i nostri clienti
ora è molto semplice se utilizziamo
all'altezza lasciamo perdere il peso
così che un po di pancetta non sente in
colpa se una persona è alta un metro e
sessanta porterà una s se nelle persone
alta 2 metri e 10 porterà un'aia l un ex
l se noi invece vogliamo ad estrarre per
esempio un algoritmo a capire a che
prezzo vendere un appartamento possiamo
farglielo correlare col numero di stanze
più stanze all'appartamento e più
costerà se vogliamo rifare un altro
algoritmo capire se una foto c'è
una motocicletta un'automobile possiamo
farglielo correlare col numero di ruote
se a due ruote è una moto se a quattro
ruote è un'automobile facile vero il
problema è che tutto questo non tiene
conto di un concetto molto importante
machine learning che correlation is not
cause e shawn ovvero la correlazione fra
due fatti non implica per forza che uno
si era causa dell'altro per capire cosa
intendo dire guardiamo questo grafico
questo grafico ci dice che il consumo di
mozzarella pro capite in america è
correlato con il numero di persone che
sia dottorando in ingegneria civile
ora è vero questo è vero che mangiare
mozzarella scenda ingegneri migliori beh
naturalmente no ma se noi diamo in pasto
questi dati un algoritmo di machine
learning e gli chiediamo di predire
quante persone sia il dottorato in
ingegneria civile apparentemente sarà
perfettamente in grado di farlo anche se
lo farà in base al ragionamento
completamente sbagliato
ora torniamo indietro al nostro esempio
dell'uomo in cucina nella terza foto è
evidente che ci sia un uomo guardiamo
come vestito guardiamo la corporatura e
lineamenti i capelli ma allora perché
l'algoritmo ha deciso che questa persona
fosse una donna
beh perché nei dati utilizzati per
addestrare la rete neurale nelle scene
in cucina c'erano quasi sono donne e
quindi l'algoritmo avete ovviamente
generalizzato che sia una persona fa in
cucina allora deve essere una donna
questo introduce un secondo concerto
molto importante nel campo dei machine
learning che garbage in garbage out se
voi utilizzate dai dati sbagliati
spazzatura che contengono dei pregiudizi
per addestrare il vostro algoritmo la
guida imparerà un ragionamento sbagliato
ragionamento spazzatura imparerà re
pregiudizi contenuti nei dati
ora questo esempio naturalmente poco
interessante
a chi può interessare un algoritmo che
ragiona come un uomo degli anni 50 che
convinto che il posto delle donne sia la
cucina un buon articolo per la colonna
delle crisi tra di un giornale ma niente
di più ma se non immaginiamo un
algoritmo usato nelle aule di tribunale
e se immaginiamo che poi strago ritmo
sia utilizzato per stabilire la pena da
comminare all'imputato immaginiamo
ancora che l'algoritmo un certo punto
decida che in base alle caratteristiche
fisiche da imputato per esempio in base
ai capelli rossi allora se i capelli
rossi sono più cattivo e quindi mi
merita una pena più aspra sembra
ridicolo sembra una distopia quasi ma
questo è quello che succede al giorno
d'oggi negli stati uniti in molti stati
americani infatti i giudici sono
autorizzati o addirittura incoraggiati a
utilizzare un algoritmo letto di risk
assessment o valutazioni del rischio che
in base a circa 150 parametri stabilisce
la possibilità che all'imputato di
commettere nuovi reati
i giornalisti di pro pubblica una
testata investigativo americano
indipendente hanno analizzato sette mila
e di questi punteggi e guardandoli si
sono accorti che le persone di colore
mirino sistematicamente svantaggiate da
questo algoritmo ovvero che lago ritmo
associava la pelle scura una maggior
possibilità di compiere nuovamente reati
ora come non è vero che i miei capelli
rossi mi rendono più cattivo
non è vero che la pelle nera rende le
persone più propensa al crimine
la teoria dell'invarianza della razza
che ci dice che non sono le
caratteristiche fisiche ma la
caratteristiche sociali l'ambiente in
cui vive la situazione economica a
spinge una persona a compiere atti
criminali e accettate anche milan ha già
moderna
ora purtroppo è anche vero che le
carceri americane in proporzione ci sono
molte più persone di colore
ma questo appunto avviene perché negli
stati uniti d'america le persone di
colore sono chiaramente più svantaggiate
hanno minore accesso all'educazione sono
generalmente più povere vivono un
contesto più svantaggiato ma l'algoritmo
anziché correlare tutti questi fattori
socio economici ha correlato il colore
della pelle la criminalità come il
peggior razzista del ku klux klan
ora magari voi non siete donne non siete
neri non avete i capelli rossi quindi mi
dite ma perché a me dovrebbe interessare
tutto questo è il fatto che al giorno
d'oggi gli algoritmi sono utilizzati il
vascello a rimettere senza
l'intelligenza artificiale in sempre più
ambiti ci sono algoritmi che
stabiliscono
se voi potete contrarre un mutuo ci sono
alberi finiti stabiliscono se voi
svilupperete una certa malattia ci sono
algoritmi che stabiliscono se voi siete
adatti a un certo tipo di lavoro e
senago ritmo decidesse un bel giorno che
i biondi non sono adatti a fare gli
agenti di commercio o se un algoritmo
decidesse se l'algoritmo di facebook
decidesse che le persone che votano un
certo partito
beh il loro posto non ci piacciono non
facciamogli vedere agli altri fossero
macchine autonoma decidesse in una
situazione di pericolo che è meglio
prendere sotto la persona grassa beh la
situazione non è bandire gli algoritmi
scappare da questi problemi ora non sta
a me dire se macron sembravo politico
meno ma la sua strategia per la francia
nell'intelligenza artificiale e
sicuramente ammirabile macro non vuole
che la francia sia all'avanguardia in
questo ambito e si è reso conto che lo
sviluppo dell'intelligenza artificiale
non può che passare per una commistione
fra la mia disciplina sono informatico e
la sociologia e la filosofia e si è reso
conto che questi problemi vanno
affrontati oggi
adesso subito prima che sia troppo tardi
in italia naturalmente la situazione un
po differente esiste la carta per i
diritti in internet che ci dice che le
decisioni importanti nella vita di un
cittadino non dovrebbero essere prese
esclusivamente da algoritmi dico
dovrebbero perché poi questa
dichiarazione non è stata tradotta in
legge
anzi lo scorso governo ha anche
rifiutato una moratoria sulle armi
autonome
continuando lo studio delle armi
autonome che così come i giudici
americani possono venire influenzati
dalle dalle decisioni degli algoritmi
anche le persone che usano armi autonome
anche se non è l'arma autonoma sparare
l'ultimo colpo possono venire
influenzata dalle decisioni di marmo
autonoma
se un missile decide che poi loro
obiettivo chi sono io per via di no hai
sbagliato
purtroppo però su questo tema negli
ultimi mesi c'è un assordante silenzio
da parte di tutti i partiti
eppure come abbiamo visto le machine
learning l'intelligenza artificiale
eccetera eccetera saranno sono e saranno
sempre più utilizzati in tutti gli
aspetti della nostra vita e noi dovremo
quindi avere il diritto di capire come
funzionano questi algoritmi in base a
cosa prendono le loro decisioni e quando
questo non è possibile perché molti
algoritmi sono molto difficili da
comprendere molto difficile capire
perché fanno le decisioni almeno
dovrebbe essere comprovabile la loro
oggettività e poi io non so se come dice
qualcuno
la singolarità la super intelligenza
stanno davvero arrivando ma quando
arriveranno
vogliamo cambiano pregiudizi contro gli
esseri umani grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]